And finally, moving on to the last point that I talked about was this idea of kicker lights.
So it's important to make note here that there's a couple different techniques that we can
use for our kicker lights, or essentially just to draw some accent to our scene or our
subject.
But in particular, we're still going to adhere to the same principles.
We want to make sure that we don't have too many lights or too many high intensity lights
within our scene.
We also want to take full advantage of our attenuation radius.
In particular, as you'll notice in the screenshot on the right, how we have various different
point lights within the vehicle.
These point lights are really just designed to accent various features of the vehicle,
right?
If we're selling this vehicle, we want it to look good, we want to draw the eye in.
So by setting our attenuation radius low, that light will only affect a very small part
of our scene.
So jumping back into our scene, I'm actually going to move our camera towards the interior
of the vehicle.
So with our current lighting setup, it really doesn't look bad at all, but it also doesn't
really draw my eye or my attention to various features of the vehicle.
So let's take a look actually in this lower section here by the floorboards, which is
actually pretty dark.
So I'm going to use this principle of adding various different kicker lights to basically
highlight that section.
So I'm going to go ahead and just kind of zoom down into here in the passenger side.
And let's go ahead and drag in a point light from our scene.
And you can see that it's actually snapping above.
So I'll press G to go into game mode.
Now at this point, if you have snapping turned on, this may actually be a little detrimental
trying to get this thing in the exact position.
So I'll go ahead and turn off my grid snapping here for my translation.
Now you can see that I can move these things into place.
And again, I'll get this light relatively within the location of where I want it.
OK, so we'll do the same thing.
So I'll go ahead and switch it to movable.
And you'll see my intensity right now is at eight in candelas.
If we want to stay consistent, let's go and switch it to lumen.
And I'll set this to something like, I would say like, let's go like 50.
In particular, I'm looking on the dashboard here where you can see, I can see the light
a little bit.
Because again, all I want to do is just essentially draw some attention to our scene.
All right, so I'll go ahead and set my attenuation radius fairly low.
So I'll go something like, let's say like 60.
You see now we're starting to affect just that area and kind of move this around.
Maybe I'll adjust this down to 50.
All right, so I'm going to go back to G, go into game mode, and I'll kind of zoom back
to our perspective that we looked at before.
And I'll go ahead and turn this off and turn it on.
Off and on.
So you see here with that kicker light, I'm actually drawing some attention to maybe the
speakers.
Maybe this is, you know, an amazing stereo system and we want everybody to notice it.
Right?
So this is a perfect place for those kicker lights.
So I'll go ahead and go back into game mode.
And essentially this junk track could go in and I could duplicate this light.
I could move this around here.
I could, let's say that we want to add another light up here by the steering wheel or, you
know, maybe bring some attention to the dashboard like this.
I'll move this other one down here, maybe to the console.
Right?
And then maybe we'll do a couple in the rear as well.
And maybe I'll set their attenuation radius up to something higher, maybe like 120.
Right.
And now I'm starting to get these accents.
So again, let's go back from our perspective.
I'm going to select all of my point lights and just really quickly group them.
And we'll just call these kicker lights.
And then I'll turn these off and on.
And it's very subtle.
You can kind of see what's happening.
But I'm going to go ahead and just go to these real quick.
And I'm going to adjust their intensity from 50 to 200 just so we can better see on the
video what's happening here.
So again, off, on, off, and on.
All right.
So now we're starting to fill out light.
Now, one quick little trick that I do want to show here is if you notice that we've got
these specular highlights occurring wherever the lights are in kind of the tangent angle
of the camera to the light itself, and we can actually remove some of that effect by
if we scroll down.
So in the point lights themselves, so in this case, I have all of them selected.
We have this specular scale.
So I can take the specular scale of the light and let's say we drop it at something like
And you see now it basically starts to act like a diffuse light.
So we still have the same intensity, but you can see in the reflections, it's much smaller.
It's much more mitigated and really helps to not detract the eye, but rather just help
to accent some of the various different things that we wanted to show in our in our scene.
So at this juncture, really, this now boils down to artistic interpretation or what you're
trying to create with your scene.
So by placing these lights, isolating them, creating our kicker lights and viewing from
our different angles, we can start to light our scene artistically to whatever vision
that we've set out.